nel 2010 ero manager in uno studio di
ingegneria francese possedeva un loft
ero sposato e volevo fare dei bambini ma
la vita è prepotente e a un certo punto
ho avuto dei tumori divorzio e mobbing
al lavoro ci ho messo due anni per
alzarmi dal divano quando finalmente ho
capito come fare
ho avuto un'idea ho chiamato mio padre
chiama mio padre gli dico ciao ma
facciamo così e gli dico senti io ho
lasciato il lavoro e voglio andare a
vivere un furgoncino della volkswagen e
le passioni non baciare ma specia
veronica il furgoncino della vostra che
non fa una sega prendi un camper come la
gente non rompere i
quindi il problema di mio padre non era
il lasciare tutta una vita fatta di
paletti corretta ma il furgone
il modello di furgone a 33 anni quindi
ho lasciato tutto e mi sono imbarcato in
una nuova avventura mi sono ricominciata
in realtà sono scappata perché non
sapevo come altro fare dovevo reagire in
qualche modo e ho agito scappando adesso
ne ho 43 e nella vita mi sono ricompresi
cominciata tante altre volte l'ultima
solo due anni fa a 41 noi entriamo
nell'età adulta con una serie di paletti
regole convinzioni che creano la nostra
idea del mondo e la nostra idea di b di
valore dei nostri valori di quello che è
giusto dobbiamo fare vogliamo fare la
cosa giusta
ma chi lo ha detto che quelle cose là
sono giuste o che soltanto quelle siano
giuste definiamo due valori per iniziare
ok valore assoluto e valore relativo mi
faccio due esempi
la morte è un valore assoluto o sei
morta o non sei morta non è che puoi
essere mezza morta oggi sono morta si
usa ma non è mai morta non seguo quasi
morta magari ci sta la bellezza è un
valore relativo perché in relazione il
valore assoluto in quanto tale è così il
valore relativo e sempre in relazione ad
altri fattori che possono essere
culturali personali di gusto di società
geografici la simpatia anche io posso
essere simpatica da alcune persone
antipatica ad altre ed entrambe avranno
ragione perché un valore relativo e
personale
il nostro bagaglio di valori quindi è
fatto da cose assolute che sono valide
per tutti e che legiferano nella nostra
vita è un sacco di valori relativi
il problema è che spesso prendiamo i
nostri valori relativi come assoluti e
giusti perché sono nostri sono meglio di
te quindi una mia idea è meglio della
tua e si fa così lo vediamo spesso coi
vecchi sta roba
quando per esempio nel mio caso vengono
meglio delle certezze attraversi un
periodo di trauma a 360 gradi
crollano anche i tuoi valori e ti chiedi
ma allora quei valori la erano veramente
i miei o stavo seguendo un'idea di di
valore di vita che non era la mia gli ho
cominciato a farmi delle domande perché
senza valori per d'identità e quello che
mi è successo è stato quello stavo
costruendo un'identità adulta seguendo
dei valori che non erano funzionali per
me e non parlo di giusto sbagliato
parodi funzionale o non funzionale
perché appunto come il relativo ad
essere adatto a noi
sempre per quella storia che il giusto
chi l'ha detto cosa è giusto che c'è
solo un giusto ma come ti ricominci una
parola che mi piace molto perché abbiamo
la capacità di ricominciare c tante
volte la vita una parola che non esiste
ma la usiamo moltissimo bisogna
ridisegnare i propri valori per poi ri
creare un'identità che sia funzionale a
noi alla nostra idea di vita nel 2010
telefonava mio padre con questa idea di
di questo furgone e alla fine la cosa io
l'ho fatta io questo furgone l'ho
comprato non è stato un furgone della
volkswagen
vi presento lucio 5 metri e 64 un
renault master dell 87 segni particolari
bellissimo e il mio furgone quando tu
fai queste scelte radicali io sono un
animale social sto dei social sui social
dal 2006 è ovviamente racconto la mia
vita non tutta
ho imparato a non raccontare tutto tutto
tutto perché era un po un problema però
racconti la tua vita diventa un modo di
vivere il raccontare il divulgare
appunto per questa cosa che mi era quasi
non comprensibile all'epoca che
esistessero valori relativi diversi fra
le persone e che ognuno doveva
accogliere i propri senza rompere i
agli altri queste scelte
radicali creano disruption perché perché
romano comunque un animale sociale
seguiamo tutte le stesse regole per
quello che ci piacciono i paletti la
laurea il matrimonio la casa di
proprietà al indeterminato i bambini la
disruption fa paura fare una cosa
diversa
fa paura perché appunto fuoriesce liceo
ma questo che sta a fare stavamo tutti a
fare questa cosa che vuoi e genera
reazioni diverse ridisegnarsi è
difficile anche perché la gente che ha
in casa è nata con quella cosa là tu fai
quello perché decide di cambiare facevi
quello dove vai ti sei laureata in
architettura il mio caso perché vuoi
andare storia vera di lavoro a insegnare
alle donne a camminare sui tacchi ma che
è un lavoro quando mi sono licenziato il
l'amministratore delegato mi fa ma per
quella nuova che zampetti sui tacchi sì
ma è un lavoro si nei suoi valori non lo
era ma nei mesi ea cosa serve che io dia
potere alla sua opinione relativa su una
mia scelta non serve a niente però
gliela diamo spesso quindi sono
dell'idea che bisogna riflettere molto
bene ai valori relativi e ai giudizi che
noi stessi anche facciamo sui valori
degli altri accogliere i nostri veri
valori è difficile perché viviamo una
società che grosso modo ci racconta
sempre la stessa roba quindi per esempio
gli adesso di lavoro insegno così come
io mi sono reinventata con questa roba
surrealità che poi lo fatte altre ho
inventato una un'agenda con un in corno
che in call che in pala un tipo
divertentissima può non piacere ma
insomma ho fatto tutto quello che volevo
ed è stato meraviglioso
a raccontare questa cosa genera molte
appunto commenti idee degli altri
io quello che ho fatto è stato
accogliere i miei valori sempre in modo
legale sempre e ne ho fatto quello che
ho voluto per la mia vita ho ridisegnato
la mia vita soprattutto partendo dal
lavoro la mia vita il mio lavoro le
amici le amicizie la città dove vivo
vivevo a parigi adesso vivo a milano
ascoltando i valori che erano funzionali
all idea che avevo per me di vita ideale
terme non per un aspettativa altrui
sembra una cavolata ma non lo è i valori
assoluti sono pochi quelli relativi sono
tantissimi
il vero problema al giorno d'oggi e
capire tutti quelli che sono relativi e
in che modo
noi li usiamo relativamente con gli
altri
io sto sui social ve l'ho detto lo tanti
anni fa su twitter con un blog adesso
molto su instagram e le persone
commentano quello che io faccio c'è
tutta una schiera di persone che creano
profili apposta falsi senza nome senza
niente zero fan per dirmi che i miei
capelli fanno cagare che lo shatush è
fatto male non va bene basta con lo
shatush l'eco guarda a me piace no no no
no no fa schifo ma va bene a me piace
no no no in chiama la pesantezza della
gente ma veramente in quel caso però io
avevo capito e lo stavo dicendo ma non
gli ho detto
detto guarda a me piace è un
mio valore non importa che sia il tuo se
a te non piace va benissimo così però
dall'altra parte aveva una persona che
prendeva un suo valore relativo come
assoluto e ha generato un conflitto
immaginate a tutti i conflitti che
abbiamo con le suocere per queste cose
tantissimi ok sempre sui social quando
tu mostri che fai qualcosa e io gli ho
fatto una una firma di empowerment far
vedere che faccio delle cose che mi
sbaglio che mi fa male che ci riprovo è
molto importante far vedere un esempio
proattivo di azione perché l'unica cosa
a far cambiare le cose e mettersi in
moto di fare il primo passo è provarci
magari con un piano ma provarci
il confronto di chi guarda i social dal
famoso divano e vede qualcuno che sta
facendo qualcosa secondo le sue idee che
possono essere assolutamente non
apprezzate ce n'era una reazione molto
strana è molto diffusa che notato
ultimamente l'avrete notato anche voi vi
criticano per quello che state facendo
non appena fatto un errore io credo
sinceramente che il vedere qualcuno che
si adopera per fare qualcosa della
propria vita ed è felice di quello che
fa perché ha accolto la funzionalità dei
suoi valori ne ha fatto qualcosa di
proprio quindi è felice lo fa vedere
risveglia l'inattività di chi guarda si
rende conto che non sta facendo niente
ed è molto pericoloso ed è un attacco
continuo è una pena che io combatto ma
non sappiamo come combattere perché con
molte persone l'esempio proattivo genera
proattività molte mi dicono a da quando
tu racconti che mai dalla psicoterapeuta
tutte le settimane
io pensavo prima che fosse da gente mata
non che io non lo sia
però ho cominciato andarci anch'io ma
figata
grazie divulgare raccontare far vedere
esempi diversi cambi ai punti di vista
delle persone ed una militanza
bellissima che non smetterò mai di fare
raccontarsi per farle lo potete fare
tutti
se fate qualcosa raccontatelo perché le
persone pensano che esistano solo quei
valori assoluti lì e che non esistano
altre opzioni invece esistono e le
dobbiamo raccontare noi dobbiamo farci
portavoce
io un certo punto sono scesa dal furgone
e nel frattempo avevo maturato dei
valori e una vita per me sono stata
prima freelance e di recente ho aperto
una srl
io ho assunto 13 persone tutte donne due
delle quali già incinta e sono stata
molto contrariata da questa cosa perché
sono entrambi i maschi come farò
assumerli dopo io non lo so
il welfare è una cosa molto importante
per noi e io la sto portando avanti a
modo mio
e importante che capiamo i diritti che
abbiamo
quando la una delle la prima ragazza che
la mia assistente che mi ha annunciato
che era incinta era terrorizzata e detto
dio c'è un problema col bambino
ma sono incinta capirai viviamo con dei
valori che dobbiamo proattivamente
muoverci con l'azione e con l'esempio
per cambiargli perché se non cambiano
qua in tutti noi non cambieranno
nell'opera di tutti i giorni nelle
azioni di tutti i giorni nell'assumere
sono donne senza pensare che sia un
casino perché a un certo punto finiranno
ragazzi siamo usciti tutti dalla
qua dentro è parlando di diritti voi
credete che mia nonna classe 1923 a 33
anni ossia il 56 sarebbe potuto entrare
un'agenzia immobiliare di milano
affittare 300 metri quadri di ufficio in
corso italia con la sola imposizione del
suo 730
no quindi abbiamo fatto tanta strada e i
diritti ne abbiamo tantissimi non lo
siano
o almeno non li usiamo tutti usare i
propri diritti oltre che ai nostri
doveri apre tantissime porte capire che
esistono capire che abbiamo tantissime
possibilità e accettare il fatto che ce
lo possiamo permettere che possiamo
farlo
ne parlo per tutti in particolare nel
mio caso alle donne perché ci auto
castriamo molto ma vale per tutti
usiamoli i nostri diritti se una roba
non ci piace perché non rispetto ai
nostri valori
rifacciamo un piano pensiamo e cambiamo
situazione sensazione non succede niente
questo secondo voi un valore assoluto
relativo
non è un valore non esiste la prova
costume ragazzi non esiste la prova
costume è una fuffa per farci sentire
inadeguate l'abbiamo sentito da chiara
prima quando ha parlato di psicoterapia
psicologia e marketing
io per militare sempre per questa
autocastrazione questi inadeguatezza del
costume del no del nostro corpo che
l'aspetta una delle nostre cose
ma non è tutto noi siamo anche quello
che facciamo è più importante di come
appariamo senza togliere alla salute
all'aspetto che è importante ma siamo
soprattutto le nostre azioni il nostro
operato nel mondo nella società
noi siamo azione quest'estate ho venduto
messo in vendita 500 costumi per far
divulgare le nostre ragazze e sono state
la fine settecento e ne volevano altri
quindi abbiamo seminato le spiagge
italiane di divulgatrici del sentirsi
per come si è stato un successo
pazzesco sono veramente felice di questa
cosa e l'anno prossimo lo faremo ancora
questo è agire
questo è agire dall'interno per una
piega pesantissima perché per paura di
cosce di culi di casini di non sono
adeguata molte donne non vanno neanche
al mare si mettono i parroci mano con
gli short non si godono la vita la
spiaggia il nuoto il tempo con gli amici
perché non si sentono adeguate e
gravissimo e bisogna agire
io vi dico solo questo
la vita inizia dove finisce il divano
cercate di trovare i vostri valori
relativi veri quelli che siano
funzionali alla vostra vita perché
spesso ce lo dimentichiamo e ch shamo
come ha detto anche un altro speaker
nelle abitudini e le abitudini
se non sono proattive sono una pessima
idea
alzatevi qualcuni dalle sedie promettete
che farete qualcosa alzatevi casa
alzatevi
la vita iniziata finisce al divano
grazie